السرعه والبقاء في الخفاء بعيدا عن عيون
مسيرات العدو سمات اساسيه لعمل هؤلاء
المقاتلين الاوكران في واحده من اخطر
الجبهات الجنوبيه في مقاطعه دنيا
في هذه النقطه المتقدمه في جبهه افديفيكا
غربيه مدينه دونيتسك يدرك المقاتلون خطوره
الموقف لذا يبقون على اعدادهم قليله في كل
موقع
طائره مسيره تغنيهم عن فرق الاستطلاع كما
يقولون يرينا المقاتلون كيف رصدوا مواقع
الجنود الروس كل ما عليهم الان هو ادخال
الاحداثيات على هذا المدفع وضرب نقاط
المرصوده
كيلانا يستخدم المسيرات للرصد والكلينه
ايضا حدود لا تستطيع المسيرات تجاوزها
والتركيزه على ايقاف التسلل ومسانده قوات
المشاه
نرافق الجيش الى موقع اخر من هذه الجبهه
هنا يستخدم الجنود سلاح الهاون للتصدي
للمشاه
لكنهم يشاركون في المعارك ايضا حين تتقدم
بعض الاليات يدرك المقاتلون قدم هذا
العتاد لكن الظروف كما قالوا تحتم عليهم
استخدام ما تقع عليه ايديهم
الوضع شديد التقلب هنا وحين يستخدم الروز
المدرعات يلجئوننا الى الاحتماء لكننا مع
هذا نضطر الى تطوير الهجوم المعاكس
بالتنسيق مع القطاعات الاخرى
يحرص المقاتلون
على لمشاغله العدو
فافديفكا على مرمى حجر من عاصمه
الانفصالهم لذلك يبقون اعينهم مفتوحه على
تحركات الروس ويرقضون كل خطواتهم مع
احتدام المعارك في مدينه باخموت مجددا
تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه للتصعيد في هذه
الجبهه لتشتيت جهود القوات الروسيه الشكوى
من ضعف الامكانات وقله العتاد مستمره لكن
الروح القتاليه لهؤلاء المقاتلين تبدو
بحال جيده عمر الحاج الجزيره من مدينه